اداء صواريخ كنجال الروسيه المتقدمه زرع
شكوكا لدى القياده الروسيه حول حقيقه ما
يجري داخل معاهد تكنولوجيا الاسلحه حيث
يتم تصنيع هذه الصواريخ فاسقاط اوكرانيا
في الرابع من مايو الماضي صاروخ كنجال
الذي تفوق سرعته سرعه الصوت لم يمر مرور
الكرام في الكرامل السلطات الروسيه اعتقلت
ثلاثه علماء من معهد نوفوسيبيرس
للميكانيكا النظريه والتطبيقيه المتخصص
بتطوير تكنولوجيا تلك الصواريخ
الكسندر شبليوك رئيس المختبرات
التكنولوجيه للصواريخ التي تفوق سرعتها
سرعه الصوت وزميليه ان توليما
بتهمه الخيانه العظمى بعد صدور حكم نهائي
بملفاتهم
فضيحه اعتقال علماء الاسلحه الروسيه لا
تقف هنا فقد تبين ايضا ان هيئه الامن
الفيدرالي الروسي اعتقلت في صيف العام
الماضي عالما رابعا من المعهد نفسه وهو
ديميتريكولكير رئيس احد ابرز المختبرات
المعنيه بتكنولوجيا الاسلحه ليفرق الحياه
بعد يومين
16 عالما من المعهد حكموا بتهم الخيانه
العظمى بحسب ما كشفته مقاله في صحيفه
ديموسكو تايمز اعتقال العلماء الثلاثه خرج
الى العالم من المعهد نفسه بحيث اصدر
المعهد بيانا احتجاجيا اعلن فيه تضامنه مع
العلماء واصفا اياهم بالوطنين ومؤكد ان
سجنهم سيؤثر على مستوى روسيا في تكنولوجيا
الاسلحه رساله المعهد هزت الراي العام
الروسي وطرحت جمله من الاسئله اما تعليق
الكريم الوحيد كان ان بوتين يثق بتحقيقات
هيئه الامن الفيدرالي وبالتالي يؤكد خيانه
هؤلاء العلماء لبلددهم
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات